so for both of you now we do get like
the necessary broad Strokes for your
characters but I can't help but to
wonder given where we find them in this
film did you develop any backstory that
we can now feel kind of informing your
performances and their decisions in the
story that we see in the final feature
um yeah sure I think like a lot of the
uh kind of work that research I did that
I felt was relevant to the backstory was
actually kind of in-depth Research into
West Point itself as an institution and
working out what that institution
represented in this time and how it
affected the cadets that train there and
and just the type of personalities they
were kind of attempting to breed there
you know and and what their drives and
motivations were and once you kind of
have an understanding of that you it
told me so much about the kind of uh
inner life and and the pressures that
that Artemis may have been under I think
I bet for you Lucy I guess mine was more
were local to the family and the the
home dynamic between all of them and
trying to work out
uh Leah's trajectory towards I mean we
find out very early on in the film that
she's battling with this illness that
very much defines
how she is but also therefore informs
how she wants to be presented and how
she tries to behave in public and around
people versus with her family and so it
was trying to
get to the origins of that and working
out a kind of timeline trajectory in a
more analytical way than I usually would
I think usually it's kind of uh instinct
or emotions based uh backstory and this
was much more kind of technical
analytical timeline in order to then
find out where we are just before the
film starts and then let that inform the
the character's trajectory now let's say
I told you both that I was going to
Brand this entire interview a spoiler
interview and Repose that question to
you in terms of what they're really up
to and why they're open to it maybe how
they found it
oh yeah
um then that becomes a much more
invested version of that of like when
um illness and confronting the constant
threat of death turns into I will do
anything to not have to face it which
turns into the extreme of bartering for
your life and the Ducks duct apps you're
willing to go to in order to do that and
at the end of the day I think that is a
kind of
Justified fight to live
but it was working out when she started
realizing that there was an there was a
path to go down that she hadn't seen
before and that she therefore kind of
pulls her family in along as well and
they're all they all become kind of
complicit in this
dark Road I could watch a whole prequel
movie oh my God your characters and just
seeing them come to this conclusion and
trying to navigate the scenario so
because we're talking about spoilers
let's talk about that big ending set
piece first for that when you're looking
at a script and you're preparing to
shoot something like that what is uh
something on the script that you kind of
circle in red and you say like that beat
or that particular part of the
production is going to be the most
challenging for me and then ultimately
when you shot it was that indeed the
biggest challenge or did something else
Catch You by surprise no I think it was
a challenge to shoot it took quite a
while to to create
um because it's quite a big set piece in
the kind of structure of the film and of
course it's the kind of um emotional and
and uh plot climax I suppose and um and
you really I think when you're in a
project like this and just as an actor
in general you feel a responsibility to
kind of give the audience the the payoff
that they deserve the payoff that
they've earned you know and I'm hoping
that we did that but it was also you
look at those uh those scenes in the
script and you can kind of
try to realize them as much as you can
in your imagination but really you don't
get a sense of it until you're there on
the day and you see all these elements
come together in this really brilliant
holistic kind of sense and you've got
the you know the light and the costume
and and the actors and and um and you've
got the real fabric of them of the
moment you know and that's when it
becomes just like a thrill that's when
it's like
you're making a movie you know it's it's
uh just fun and um as long as you can
kind of stick to your task then it's
something to be to be relished I suppose
speaking of that particular moment one
of one of my favorite beats within that
sequence is basically the end for both
of your characters and I was wondering
if you could give us a little insight
into like how it is and what kind of
goals you have maybe for expressing the
fact that they're making a really
important internal decision and not
explaining it to us via dialogue like
the building is burning she decides to
stay there and keep going with the with
the ritual he knows she's dead but he
decides to stay there anyway so when
you're performing beats like that
without being able to explain those
choices what are some of your top
priorities there I think the joy is that
you don't have to explain them in a way
so you really more earnestly get to live
in it and I mean which is much easier
when as Harry was saying the set piece
is so alive I mean when you have real
Flames surrounding you it's easier to
get to that level of intensity but by
that point I mean we also shot that at
the end of the filming schedule so by
that point you're so entrenched in
understanding the stakes for your
character and how crucial it is that
this moment that this ritual is carried
out it is literally life and death and
when a person is cornered into that I
think you become so extreme and you are
clutching at any possibility of Hope and
I think that's the most poignant element
of it that even in these dire moments
where the audience can see that all odds
are against them that there is that hope
that keeps fueling all of those
characters and and that's where you I
think you do kind of you can find an
emotional access to all of them you feel
what you just described and it breaks my
heart how about for you Harry the choice
to stay there yeah absolutely and I
think um you know so much of that work
when you don't have a dialogue to kind
of uh hang on to it can almost be more
freeing and and better in a way because
it becomes instinctive and it becomes
situational and like Lucy says when you
have the fire around you I mean to be
honest it's probably like the only
moment in the entire film where we were
like warm
which was which is quite a quite a treat
really
um but yeah uh that is the kind of the
the payoff of all the kind of ambiguity
that we've tried to kind of construct in
the movie up to that point and and for
us as individuals in our own work you
know you've you've tried to layer these
characters with um with a purpose and
motivation and make them multifaceted
and interesting and complex and for us I
think that uh that desperation and that
like Foundation of love that they have
was the the thing that we really kind of
pursued in the characters and the thing
that mattered to us most and the thing
that we kind of wanted to ultimately uh
put across I got the wrap so I'll finish
with one last question that you won't be
able to answer you probably know exactly
where I'm going with this I'm sure
someone else asked you today the new
Joker movie in an effort to ask you a
safer question about that what is a I
guess a creative itch that that movie
that unique sounding production is going
to let you scratch for the very first
time
um
listen like I I can't really speak to a
movie that that hasn't uh been made
um but from what I hear the kind of the
the creative team that seemed to be
involved in that project looks
phenomenal and um I think it would be a
a dream of any actor to kind of be part
of that and so um so yeah it's a very
smart answer right there